et on va prendre tout de suite la
direction des hautes france pour
retrouver notre envoyé spécial nadège
abderrazak les hauts de france où le
président sortant les républicains
xavier bertrand a remporté la région et
vous le voyez les résultats à l'écran il
a été réélu avec 52 points 37% des voix
contre sébastien chenu du rassemblement
national 25 65 % pour karima delli qui
rassemble la gauche et des écolos avec
21,99 % des voix et on va à présent
rejoindre notre reporter nadège
abderrazak
[Musique]
bonjour nadège pari gagné donc pour
xavier bertrand dans les hauts de france
on ne change pas une équipe qui gagne
c'est visiblement ce qu'on prône ici
dans les hauts de france puisque xavier
bertrand a été réélu à la tête de la
région
alors ça menaçant de quitter
définitivement la politique en cas de
défaite à ce scrutin a visiblement et
bien permis de mobiliser ses troupes
alors il a certainement pu examiner
bertrand compter sur le report d'une
partie des voix attribuée à alors
empiétera de ses skis et au premier tour
le candidat de la république en marche
avait à ce moment-là recueilli 9,1 pour
cent des voix le candidat de la majorité
présidentielle avait tout de suite en
dimanche dernier reconnu sa défaite et
appelé en faveur de xavier bertrand pour
faire barrage au rassemblement national
alors xavier bertrand signe donc un
second mandat de six ans à la tête de la
région des hauts de france mais lui a
visiblement les yeux déjà rivés vers
2022 puisqu'il s'est déjà porté candidat
il estime que la victoire d'hier lui a
donné les force d'aller à la rencontre
des français qui en 2028 m'ont fait
l'honneur de m'accorder à nouveau leur
confiance
durant cette campagne je vous ai dit la
vérité
j'ai été clair sans rien vous cacher de
mes intentions
ce résultat me donne la force d'aller à
la rencontre de tous les français pour
redresser notre pays
il y à un préalable le rétablissement de
l'ordre et du respect
l'insécurité mines la république la
défigure et ce sont les plus modestes
les premières victimes un cap sur 2022
mais ça ne devrait pas être
simplissime mais en tout cas pour xavier
bertrand à des gens absolument il a
quitté les républicains à xavier
bertrand il ya trois ans mais il estime
être le mieux placé pour apporter la
victoire à la droite en 2022 sauf que
d'autres pensent également pouvoir faire
la même chose
c'est le cas par exemple de valérie
pécresse a réélu hier dans la région ile
de france ou encore de laurent wauquiez
vainqueur dans la région à rhône
auvergne rhône-alpes à leur rock
ne parlez pas de primaire à xavier
bertrand il n'en veut pas il ne veut pas
de ce système de départager c'est ce
qu'ils pourraient aussi compliquer son
sa candidature pour 2022 en tout cas on
sait on imagine en tout cas qu les
discussions et les débats devront
pourront être compliqué mouvementée dans
les mois à venir
à droite merci beaucoup nadège il reste
encore quelques mois et on va suivre
cela bien sûr merci beaucoup nadège
abderrazak en direct des hôtes france ce
matin